hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom eternal I am on
what might be the last level of the game
I'm not on a censure and with the last
level I want to try something I've been
playing on ultraviolence as people know
and if anyone's doubted me I have been
known for violence I want to see what
nightmare is like because I've gotten
pretty good at ultraviolence so I kind
of want to know what this is gonna have
for me now I got to use my crucible you
know to be perfectly honest I have not
been using it pretty yes very Jesus like
lots of crosses halos and angels and
stuff and very pretty I like it dak this
is er dak the homeworld of the makers a
brief age analysis that the structures
in architecture here indicates that this
world is older than any other in our
databases similarities can be also be
drawn to multiple pangalactic religions
indicating that the makers influence was
not limited to arts and DeNooyer and
that over eons of influence has spread
across the galaxy and potentially the
universe some imagery is akin to
religious icons in the Orion Cygnus arm
of the Milky Way in Aria which includes
earth the name er DAC is common tongue
in the maker language but can be
approximately translated to the word for
paradise or having in hundreds of
different languages further cementing
the theory that the makers have been a
religious impact on mortal beings for
millions of years
despite their seeming godliness the
makers have a past at some point in
their ageless history there is mention
of the father a logical alien entity
that endowed the makers with their vast
knowledge and technical ability so even
the makers had a God it's just always
one God above the other one analysis of
maker artifact said scripture indicate
that the father may have been a singular
being that split to form the maker race
or instead transferred his incalculable
power into the vast structure known as a
deck which then birth the makers in
perpetuity it seems that the makers
through exceptionally long-lived
eventually suffer some form of
biological and mental degradation at
which point they undergo a process known
as a Transfiguration wherein they allow
a voluntary death and resurrection
somehow tied
the father this process may have been
complicated or damaged in the recent
past there are no records of how the
father came to the makers when it was
first discovered or if it had any
physical form before the makers the
first mention of the father is in regard
to a building named the lunare Luna
Luminarium who was a temple of sorts
we're makers would go to seek answers
the essence of the father was stolen by
one of their own by a maker referred to
as the Seraphim who the third Seraphim
is or what he did with the father's
consciousness is unknown records show
that one day the Luminarium simply
ceased to communicate and that the deep
scan of its databanks revealed no
remaining trace of the entity or DAC
itself exists in an anchor state
utilizing highly advanced dimensional
shift technology to allow static
position at a sub quantum level this
essentially inverts their position in
relation to hell both planes of
existence are fixed outside of bounds
known of the known universe a lower and
higher reality the con maker oversees
all with inner DAC and now utilizes
argent energy to prevent the
Transfiguration well that's confusing
also where did I get 10 suit points 10
suit points that's preference just
upgrade all of my [ __ ] all right cool
do it let's do it to it all gonna need
it on nightmare they're all my favorite
oh is that top had to do them guy that's
awesome what else could I possibly
upgrade here okay I'm getting I'm
getting just a whole bunch of upgrades
going on I've got some interesting one
this one says it'll oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah this'll drop ammo on kills my micro
missiles is now bottomless and never
needs to reload this no longer stalls
which I'm guessing means it doesn't
overheat probable glibly oh that looks
fun oh here I go glad I just guessed
that's how that worked
who's here there any enemies yeah that's
cool but I don't need it
well it's awfully pretty here love the
design I got it me love the design I
think the story is still confusing and
convoluted and overly complicated but
this just got dim beautiful as far as
the set piece goes I don't even care why
I'm here I don't even care what their
long and
story in history is let me see what I
got a kill seems awfully peaceful I
definitely smell something funky going
on here hmm
yes I'm guessing Oh thought I was gonna
miss that
well glad they've got one funkalicious
navigation system do the little old doom
guy going for a little bit of a jaunt
whee oh god I missed it I didn't know I
still had jump juice left
you really did I don't know pop pop pop
oh boy oh okay all right sure
whatever you say we we thank you we
thank you we thank you fascinating all
right I think this is where the fun
begins
all right nightmare mode let's see what
you got let's see what you got
who's here Oh some nice laser to you out
there am I supposed to go down
aha interesting
ah fascinating there's a secret up top
and there's an auto map here they're
just giving me the auto map they're
really just giving that to me so when
they said something about a Seraphim
wasn't this doom guys process of
transforming into the unstoppable
killing machine that he is something to
do with the gut and the Seraphim
Seraphim which i think is another word
for angel is there a way to get up there
how do you bowed you right yep
easy-peasy let me up there man why'd
they build it so convoluted up here yup
you it just wants to make sure that you
get all the weapon upgrades that's all
this is about which I appreciate don't
get me wrong
I'm all about that bypass baby bypass
bypass alright that worked edges do dish
I'm ready to kill something very dead I
don't exactly have know if they're gonna
send demons after me are they gonna send
these dudes which I fought in one of the
special places Seraphim Seraphim
man I got a hunch I should stand up
straight hi what's going on guys oh hi
nice an icon cannot stop the procession
little kid I would kid I know that's
that thing that betrayer gave me finally
oh hell yeah
black no one in this room tried to stop
me
that thing's huge probably has huge guts
oh that's not good hmm
all right my big strong hands couldn't
grab on to that where boy yeah that's a
little physically weird all right maker
drone is ranged fodder demon oh but I
just got the micro missiles
all right fine then let me change over
in point man it really does it really
does
well that hurts spicy - spicy damage
whoa
these guys really hurt yeesh nightmare
is no joke
oh not you baby not you please please go
away
thank you please die Wow who did that
oh god I miss whoa whoa I'm wrong wrong
wrong
whoa my god jeezum nightmares redonk
mist mist you die oh my god you die okay
oh my god
okay must be two extra lives just to get
through this portion where Oh God not
you I'm still fighting people man my
armor just I can't hear you exactly
[Music]
can't you wolf in do alright well that
was a new experience and I don't think
I'm getting as much armor back on that
maybe I am I have no idea all right
well anyway that's fun probably able to
do that a little smoother now that I
know exactly what I'm in for
oh wait wait secrets there's got to be
secrets no no and I used up two of my
swore T's but frankly for the bests wait
wait for it I've made a horrible error
alright
whoa whoa okay what do we got what do we
got going on here there's something up
there
question mark literally a question mark
up there the icon of sin as it was
written in the prophecies of ancient
Sentinel scripture the Titans towering
elder demons of the infernal age would
return on earth from their immortal
slumber the times are believed to be
harbingers of the end times primordial
forces of chaos and destruction born
from the tortured spirit of the
betrayers son it was by Hell's to hold
anole design that the icon of sin was
given flesh the fearsome Titan forged
from the essence of mortal suffering
once for a human soul a soul now
transmogrified and entombed within the
still being heart of its former owner
the betrayer seeking to free his son
from eternal torment within the depths
of Hell made an agreement a pact sealed
by the black fates of darkness that
promise to grant his son the chance to
return from death the son would live
again but not as human in Hell's endless
cruelty the son was damned to become the
icon an inhumane existence bound only to
its former humanity either now
disembodied undying mortal heart man I
would be so pissed off and try to avenge
my son hmm man that would have been a
good final battle huh the climactic
finish between father and son nah okay
all right cool rude the scent of Serb
Iran you say all righty then
yep boy oh boy oh boy am I missing any
secrets dad piccaboo anybody here where
am I going
Oh wrong way wrong way
wait what opus Oh office okay I'm
dumbest office man you'd think that the
Angels would build some better vent
covers heya wait a minute that's not
what I meant to do Oh
Loree kill anybody else hey wait a
minute
I say no I said where did you come from
Emma pop
oh there we go okay so there's something
going on here with that and that did
what exactly
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] is that someone screaming there
I don't know why punch hey boo secret
encounter nightmare levels secret
encounter I don't have any armor right
now but you know let's see what happens
[Music]
what blood punch blood punch blood punch
what weight blood punch dudes key Jesus
Christ blood punch
oh my god are you kidding me blood punch
wouldn't do
goddamn Jack noodley
blood punch oh my god blood punches the
most inconsistent piece of garbage they
did there we go Oh God blood punch is so
inconsistent of all the things in the
gameplay sphere of this game
I say blood punch is just the the worst
it is the most poorly designed I'm
trying to punch and it doesn't blood
punch because it's the same as the
world's wimpiest punch it's like this
punch will either barely kill a fly or
it will devastate the countryside and
it's one or the other and it doesn't
always hit consistently if blunt punches
up and I go to punch an enemy it should
[ __ ] blood punch
I heard blood punch I'm sorry is the
first time I've raged about blood punch
but I've had this same feeling in out
blood punch building up in my soul just
always been just do it blood punch Oh
much dislike blood punch greatly ooh
rip and tear you say metal head did I
get all of them oh yeah oh yeah alright
what we got in here something's up there
man they make it just easy to get these
things make it easy yeah why not this
one apparently I'm supposed to not use
the micro missiles that I had just
unlocked supposed to use the precision
bolt
there is a buff totem nearby apparently
whoa hey you hi baby
peekaboo I don't see you all got 200
points of damage I'm gonna die again
we all got none of them were you can't
chainsaw this thing I thought you said
it was fodder oh my god where's the
totem where's the totem where's the
totem where's the totem person told him
where's there it is I see it
hey good say you're you guys are in
trouble now I've got blood punch enabled
and you know how devastating that could
be punch a black box my god just do it
when I asked you to do it that's all I
want
what the hell just happened I did not
change some what are you you you're not
who I want to fight right now not that
close anyway
who why are other people joining this ah
I gotcha
Oh God you go you oh my god you are
gonna know this wrong yeah good thing I
blood punched Oh Warren Ellie what do I
got what do I got ah there we go
man I am named there's no joke all of my
bonus lives gone goddamn it
what's coming in where is he he's going
to get blood punched this is how we do
this is how we do it in blood watch land
it didn't do anything who did that who
yeah stop nightmare is a dick
oh man nightmare is a dick well how
long's let's me pissing myself cuz
apparently I piss gasoline oh but it's
fun is a nightmare is fun god maker
every ten thousand years of collective
maker consciousness noticed the
singularity Bursa Khan maker the Supreme
Being destiny bound to leave the Oliver
dock until the next Khan is born the
singularity which contains the conscious
soul data for every maker that has ever
lived and died processes and refines his
data as a means of selective evolution
as hierarch of the conscious neural
matrix to which each maker is
interconnected it is physically
impossible for a maker to refuse the
collective order of shared
consciousnesses and disobey a con the
system is functioned without error since
the creation of verdict until now with
the disappearance of the father the
makers are incapable of creating a
successor to the Khan lineage allowing
the existing conda holder claim to the
throne indefinitely okay sounds good
great I don't see a problem here did
this really need a puzzle here
hate it hey hey you guys hey wait whoa
whoa whoa buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy what's going on over
there
Alex fancy I like that sounds like a
storm's brewing somewhere Raleigh
symbolic or not it's on earth why is it
on earth why would that thing be on
earth why how did it get there
I have many questions there's something
below me I found it oh that's the other
thing I just don't like the character of
the con maker it's like a blogger I just
don't like
[Music]
no no a dacha I'm not used well there I
go buy food not cool what oh my god are
you not a thing that can actually be
killed oh oh my god this is ridiculous
this is insanity oh my god just let me
let me type your stupid hand what punch
there we go frickin work that time there
we go
whoa my blood punch is ready I'm super
excited
hey what are you doing here alright
nightmare mode baby nightmare mode new
I'm gonna go bro yeah get stuck can I
goddammit whoa God dude Oh juice son of
a [ __ ] if that thing would have killed
me I would have been very upset
come on what do you get
Oh God blown to smithereens where am I
why am I here what happened why would
you do that to me
I've been a nightmare runner and that's
how you're gonna treat me girl I don't
like you
whatever that was it just teleported me
why all right whatever it's fun it's all
good all right so how do I get into this
mystery chamber ah oh you don't say oh
thank you I don't need this anymore this
is worthless but I appreciate it and I
appreciate you who the hell are you
alright why are there demons in heaven
no insert finger that's weird
vague is really powerful system acquired
setting the course for the earth
dimension now
the San Anton
you must get the other teleporter rings
a line before it's too late the gate
must be reactivate the longer the icon
of sinners on earth the stronger he
willed the car well why why why would
that what what what new Vega what what
what's what do I do
oh I'm more than a little confess old
just a little bit I birds from dojo now
that's gonna do me anything I can't get
to you from downtown
well run the knick all right who's gonna
get a face full of missiles that was a
little unnecessary
all right who's doing that boink nope
you bastards I give up trying to get you
to go play along just be a good whatever
you well there we go
and just well what is happening here
what am I seeing
oh my god oh my god oh my god okay all
right yeah I see I see what you want me
to do that's how we do baby whoa whoo oh
my god arts file where'd you come from
buddy no not that one
no not that one lock on to the arts file
that's not why did that happen I did not
want to waste my BFG on that it auto
switch to the BFG did I accidentally hit
Q or something I think Q switches
weapons all right whatever I'll take
I'll take it
they're dead now I did it I don't know
I'm not using the unmake er either why
is it on the BFG I wanted to use the
unmake er but I have no more ammo
anymore you could say I wanted to use
the unmake er because I could do it for
more than just one shot whatever it's
fun I'm having fun that's all that
matters
whoa whoa who's being a douche you
you're being a douche stop it what do we
got
make her angels these oh just this nice
these revered figures service speakers
for the con maker earning positions of
leadership and high esteem within their
species
angels avert a cart gifted with Oracle
rings golden halos a fuse to their armor
as a symbol of their status and rank
these divine beings occasionally
gathering calm claves or at the summons
of the con maker but typically do not
work together instead being assigned as
independent advisors and overseers
amongst maker controlled worlds next
you're gonna tell me that Samuel Aiden
is a maker hahaha
not really secret oh I hate it
do these go anywhere I guess I'm here
now oh oh oh God
[Music]
hi you shouldn't be sleeping
good told you that wasn't gonna end well
for you melted that person this is what
I need to do perfect great
I spy with my little eye glug glug glug
something that is purple pink pur pur
pink oh one up you say I'll use that
irresponsibly all right let's do this
who wants to melt all right I need to
get this you're gonna go 200 no not
today
oh my god really are you kidding me oh
my god are you kidding me there we go
you fall down you die dodging my rail
guns no thank you
this is a very inferior rail gun by the
way why this is an instantaneous hit
I'll never know hey wait no I should do
this that's what I should do I see with
my little eye some [ __ ] who thinks
they're better than me
and the answer is go to hell who's there
much bigger than I thought it'd be ah
Who am I next to where am I
yeah let me get out here no yeah that's
right
okay I'm gonna get you oh yeah oh yeah
I'm gonna blood punch you so hard oh yes
that's how we do boink yes pippity
poppity hop we got oh yeah oh yeah you
go down you go down you go boom oh yeah
oh yeah that's what I'm talking about
Oh more Oh more Oh interesting
interesting interesting interesting
where am i no oh my god oh my god up
there we go alright here we go
new start dead
that was a sweet blood punch right there
Oh nope nope nope nope
damn I almost had that too I'm gonna
start all the way over nightmare is
brutal but that was mostly just me
getting hit up against objects and [ __ ]
alright let's do this
this time no joke miss okay it's a joke
dad who's that oh come on do it my god
that was ridiculous get oh my god dude
it feels so good to do something like
that on nightmare-like and that feels
really good once I got into the flow of
that dude it's so fun that's so fun they
really did this right they really did it
right okay where am I headed okay it was
hubris
wow that sounds heavy I don't care all I
care about is killing demons so if
there's a big demon that needs killing
I'm happy
keep boys a space these out perfectly
yeah okay nailed it
perfect yeah perfect in every way
alright your little I really don't know
what these buttons do and also what's
the whole thing about Vega being you
know the father cuz that's a little
strange
I do new
okay secret over here what does that
mean
oh hi how do you get to you outside
oh I like that one that's a good one
that's a good toy that's a good boy
I like that cool yeah what what what
there it's a little silly okay what do I
need to do oh I need to go the other way
now okay I got it
one more big battle didn't think I was
gonna catch that one who's it oh god no
not another totem Oh God egads where is
it I don't want you took it from me
there it is
freeze okay ah no no this is AHA my god
walk on Dan oh my god might meet hook
isn't walking anymore that's a little
silly okay okay okay oh you're you were
still here Nara okay okay okay no no no
totem totem told him told him okay all
right now we're good Wow miss Jo got you
that time
that's quite a lot of you die [ __ ] oh
yes please how big are your big guy
means big guts
[Music]
so good it's so good it's so good I
can't describe how good it is god it's
good it's so good that's why I can
forgive everything else I can forgive
everything else and you know what I
don't even hate the blood punch anymore
because now that I'm playing nightmare
you know if I use it right man that's
helpful yeah I don't hate anything
anymore
I hate nothing this is great I'm so down
everything love it perfect Dada Dada 11
out of 10 200 200 it's perfect perfect
game best game ever huh okay what was I
doing okay
yeah this is secret somewhere here I'm
I'll push the button ooh
you know the icon of sin he was disabled
to go to hell instantaneously why do I
have to go through three multicolored
rings to get there they're very pretty
don't get me wrong but seems a little
strange
there's earth with the Rings fully
aligned the dimensional gate - birthday
smell open get to the landing platform
and pass through the portal earth does
not have much time left
that's okay it's alright what's the
worse it could happen
very pretty I think I saw this in four
good movie okay oh I see a half berserk
you say I could play a whole level in
pure berserk mode is what you're saying
okay
[Music]
hi
are you dodging bastard
dodge that dick hello whoa that's weird
algalon oh that looks fun not sure
what's going on there but it looks fun
oh this looks wet not sure what's going
on there but if it looks wet yay for a
little bit of armor good for me I guess
whoa what the hell is this
oh I hate it
Oh what the hell I didn't know what I
was jumping into oh it's like something
out of subnautica oh my god oh my god
what am I like it literally this is like
a scene from subnautica the hell it's so
cool
alright okay
love that see that's great I don't know
what that is but it's here and I love
that
what are you supposed to be hi can I
kill you
alright find that don't like that what
did that do
oh I can push a button now wow that was
really roundabout not sure what that was
all about but it was really round about
fast-travel unlocked wait a minute I've
gotten all these secrets so I don't
think I need to do anything else oh well
I'm fine
this is gonna be the final boss the god
maker is near she can't let you leave
this place alive funny about that
the or nice battleground this is going
to be sick
made other sacrifice in the name of our
so that maybe in German provide
retention one some water to defy our
Wow very pretty
I'm gonna die just the same so well
temporarily disable your stoop and
refill your blood
I see so now I have to use blood punch
right little where they have to explain
ooh spicy dicey spicy boom I see whoa
what are you dead are you dead
what happened I don't know what happened
oh my god
oh my god I've been taught to use this
for shields gonna do that
whoo come here come here out in the
gullet ride the gun
oh hey bud whoo that wasn't really a
head shot but I'll take it
what's that glowing in the sky and I got
some for you baby
where am I Oh every time every time Wow
oh wait what Oh God hand wash keys and
figure something out here
Oh
come on shoot damn it oh my god really
oh I got you guys okay here we go
come on oh no what can I help it was I
on that might have been the last one
okay I was just figuring it out is fun
okay all right okay okay okay okay okay
okay
here we go
now what am i roasting in what is
burning me don't dodge this please oh
she needs six blood punches okay that's
fine as long as I know what I'm in for
oh really sir Dadar sidered er can I get
some AMRO would be great okay what could
I get for her this looks good
that does pretty good damage the only
holy monoi well I did it again I keep
doing that
oh saved it Oh God now he gets where's
the little dude's got yeah Oh God does
this just hurt forever
it does it does why would I be on it of
course it hurts forever that's just what
it is
how what surface is not covered in
[ __ ] where are these little dudes
there you are
God okay let's try the skin shall we
oh my god come on come on oh my god
really
[Music]
really God are you God I think I got the
rhythm now oh my god stop doing that
oh my god I know what it is I know what
it is if I jump this pushes me back
that's what it is I did not know that
about this gun that's a new thing to
know if you choke it pushes you back
that's why I'm flopping off Oh sir lack
yeah yes sir law that makes a lot of
sense okay there we go let's try a
little bit of the OL done maker
god no get the you stop it stop it what
the [ __ ] are you done what the [ __ ] was
that so they push you back that's what
that was they push you back if you get
close so if I'm say going for the
[ __ ] hit they just push you back yeah
they just push you back that's really
weird
ow ow ow ow ow ow ow oh god damn it
ah what the [ __ ] no oh my god stop
pushing me back go go go
oh my god
there we go there we go there we go
there we go okay
oh that was it
little [ __ ] baby that was in a little
[ __ ] baby oh no no no you got blood
punched oh you got blood punched man you
sure look dude you look like a demon
down beneath that armor
now take that
now know who said no
I had no guarantee that's how that would
work
all right two blood bunged eggs
practice makes perfect on the blood
punching oh I did it oh I feel like for
that one you had to do it I guess I did
it everybody nightmare not so bad for he
will walk among us and he will smite the
evil from the earth for he who comes in
our time of need is not of morbol breed
he is the destroyer the right hand of
our creator and the one who brings fear
where there is no hope
well that doesn't sound good I doesn't
sound too happy final sin is this it is
dished up Big Poppa its dish the big
Papa Papa hey buds boy what are you
doing over there
boy got you going you fight it out you
fight it out guys
[Music]
are you still going on about that come
on
well too bad I'm gonna kill you yeah how
hard can it be to kill just one man I
thought the thing the same thing myself
several times whoa you guys are gonna
make it easy for me no you get blood
punched ow
okay do not go near that dude that's god
damn it
if it's weakness at blood punch and I
can't get near it with blood punch then
what am I supposed to do
oh my god oh my god no no not like this
not you why you suck but I know just the
recipe for you buddy
boom boom boom yes please thank you
whew just mopping up now all the little
guys sorry bud you didn't need that did
you oh hey are you doing whoa God big
guy
[Music]
yeaaaaah yeaaaaah buddy
oh god who's hit who the Frick was
hitting me oh my god I almost lost that
just because I don't know who was
hitting me then again I did stay in one
spot and try to burn almost work too
here I go again same strat I change what
is broken how was a nuts fight that
fight was bonkers oh that fight was nuts
oh that was nuts okay and you get the
screaming of the Damned over there
uh-huh no hope for survival you say well
ain't that just a crying shame
mind if I step in
thanks buds thank you for your patience
you mean yourself got him only I could
read collect all the code X's well
wanted I get final sin Oh Vega data
entry ass and not what Oh interesting
the icons presents warps reality
damaging the implicit order of our
dimension merely by existing within it
if the icon is allowed to remain
unchecked it would lead to the total
devastation of earth followed by a
breakdown of space-time around the
planet the resultant black hole will
eventually drag our entire universe down
casting it into the mouth of hell as a
conquest to be absorbed by the dark
clown I'm sure that checks out
scientifically the con maker had taken
measures to augment the tight and
installing maker technology throughout
its structure to ensure it could be
controlled with the ritual interrupted
the icon is now fully Unleashed raging
across earth until hell consumes all no
longer bound by the heart of the
betrayers son the icon of sin is free
from any measure of control that the
makers might have once conceived only
the Slayer prophesized in our agenda
legend to stand against the icon can
stop this apocalypse
so our gentle legend prophesized the
creation an icon that was a result of
the betrayal someone who cross time to
get okay cool
good good good great sure it looks like
I should be able to break through that
let me let me is God let Lemmy is let me
let me whose food lamby
whose lamby whose lamby oh okay
strange
nice what's that supposed to be
difficult because it wasn't how do I get
to that one up
I don't need it you know what I don't
really need it not even a secret in the
game it's just a one up and I'm gonna
lose it anyway so why bother
Oh opus opus opus fun oddly enough this
doesn't look as devastated as the
beginning of the game so I call this a
net positive no [ __ ] this buff totally
alright buff totem understood understood
Institute where is it
ow ow ow ow
where's buff there it is get out of here
stinky loser where to go swear to go
play love that
I don't know what was happening who's
awesome my muscles guy my masseuse got
buffed my muscles got buffed my muscles
and my muscles got bought huh
perfectly climbable wall that's built
into the superstructure of this facility
perfect perfectly perfect perfect in
every way what's going on over here oh
yeah give me that stiff give me the good
stuff oh yeah give me the good stuff oh
I'll take that offer hello oh whoa hey
oh hey bud what are you doing here
friend and I'll be with you in just a
moment okay but I can see you the doctor
will see you now
hey but war let me do something else for
you
oh oh oh eh but whoa bud bud bud
but insky whoa hey bud
peekaboo that's you hi bud Emma don't be
shy
ah goodbye your luck is worth nothing
like it were nothing like it were
nothing with it weren't almost saamana
ma summon me some mama your heads back
your their guy's head was backwards oh
you're her your melee is just about as
weak as my mail how could this be
he bonds your your friendly neighborhood
whatever the hell I am
you're big and you're dead didn't stand
a chance
Oh goodbye bud oh that's a lots of
damage he oh whoa another one of you oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god
egads thank you that's exactly what I
wanted to use at that moment can you
pour God
yes oh there I'm perfect
that turned out perfectly for me
oh there's two of youse oh there's two
of us well that calls for the unmake er
yeah
oh I'm gonna get this oh my god I'm
gonna get this glory kill on this guy if
it's the last [ __ ] thing up
[Music]
it's fine I didn't in it didn't really
need it anywhere hi bud listen I'm best
friend I'm not in the mood I didn't I
didn't get to blast who I wanted to
blast today so I really am just left to
my own devices it's okay I understand
you want to cheer me up and all but uh
buddy listen it's it's I didn't get to
glory killed nobody I mean pull what
you'll let me glory kill you
oh you're such a friend wow that's so
meaningful and nice so thoughtful
that's so all you're you shouldn't have
oh my goodness okay if you say so friend
okay okay okay okay okay okay I'll do it
thank you thank you buddy
how about oh thank you friends thank you
a true a true pal that's what you are oh
my god what happened oh no what happened
I just finished the Marauder what
happened oh that's oh no oh god damn it
I got cocky oh that's that's all me
that's all me all day that's a whoa
speaking of cocky okay how about we take
this a little more seriously because
that was a lot of progress lost I just
killed the Marauder I don't know what
combo must have hit me but it must have
been like a charged shot from a whole
bunch of other little dudes
goodbye Oh goodbye all right let's do
this
oh god he actually got me with that one
whoo oh boy oh god damn it he got me all
right Jesus oh wait now I'm up here wait
what
how are you are you doing got ya all
right nothing else is gonna get me right
that's what I thought nothing else you
mess with me you die that's how this
goes arch-vile in the field
hard foul in the field arch-vile is on
the field arch-vile is gonna get a face
full of BFG where is it where you having
to Duke there you are
okay I'm gonna hit him from this angle
Oh direct it how are you alive how are
you alive my dude you are tough yeah
is it time you're finally time to fight
the icon better be oh that was tough
that was really tough nightmare mode
baby nightmare mode
I stupidly booboo assumed a little bit
the bus okay sure I wonder where that
lady is broadcasting from and where the
hell like if it even is a person which I
don't think it is I think it's just a
program or something what are Y uh-huh
anything up here that I need not by the
looks of it
all right let's get this let's do this
boss fight time Bob oh uh yeah oh really
god you're gonna like give me I hate
these polls I don't like um no no Oh
didn't mean it didn't it didn't mean it
didn't need it did not need it all right
what do we got there it's super
unfortunate I have like an odd stack so
I got to use the unmake er I mean I say
I gotta use the animaker I'm totally
down to using on maker
as it was written how do you know all
this Samuel ad
okay
okay lalalalalalala on maker time I
don't know if this is the best strategy
but I just felt like doing it oh yeah
this feels good
whoa see people here people are here
apparently
whoo
[Applause]
whoo oh my god what hit me something hit
me good on maker time I'm gonna go for
that health thing
I can't believe the unmake er is only
doing that much damage so I feel like it
should be doing way more damage
[Music]
to dive I messed that man Cuba's up oh
my god
No thank you nothing give me something
else what happened what landed up did it
make you miss land on me really a make
you piss landed on me well that's unfair
all right I'm gonna go I'm gonna see
what what does that do oh okay all right
interesting
I've almost got something going on oh my
god oh my god oh no no okay this one's
just a complicated fight whoa where did
I go he punched me off the building one
eternity later ok I did it I think I got
the oh he's leaving
Oh nice ass what no what what oh ok all
right take ok alright ok shoot oh god I
gotta do the eight body parts again that
sure you know what fine it's old what
wait I have many reservations about this
as a final boss battle but you know it's
fine
I'm just gonna take this as seriously as
I can I'm still playing on nightmare by
the way so that's why it's being
brutally difficult he's gonna do the
same thing he's just doing the same
thing same thing he was doing now in big
mode oh there is no way
oh my god dude
Jesus Christmas dramedy oh god no no
okay well there goes my death protection
but not that that's gonna do me a lot of
good when I'm being assaulted from all
sides at the same time
oh don't scream it god I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead oh my god I'm dead I'm dead we'll
give me something to chainsaw you oh my
god this is insanity this is insanity oh
god I walked right into that
oh no I'm dead I'm dead um no I didn't
want to go up I didn't want to go up I
didn't want to go up give me something
anything healthy oh not you god damn it
oh my god
you could I you can i yes give me you
okay god those guys
what is happening oh my go my god it's
Giga beam I need to get under get under
shits Christmas Oh kick me now oh my god
okay ow ow ow ow no no no now when I've
come this far
spawn and you die get down
good god good god good god
he's so close oh my god no no no oh my
god what hit me holy [ __ ] no no no no
not like this yes oh I think he just
needed to finish an animation or
something yes bury that [ __ ] in his
brain oh my god yes please oh yes oh you
wait no I think you were supposed to
leave that in there the whole sword
[Music]
and you will be the savior your strength
will be there shoot as your will their
sword you
[Music]
for you all right is internal
all right now I want to say very early
on that was great game great game great
great great game great game the gameplay
itself was so fantastic the boss battle
it's so hard to get a boss battle that
really lives up to the hype of the game
and I feel like that one especially the
first phase was much more frustrating
than it was fun it was just so hard to
read when he was gonna punch it just
seemed like random where and when he was
going to do something so like I would be
fighting the other demons and then
randomly I would just get squashed
because I was there then again I was
playing on nightmare I upped my
difficulty to nightmare just because I
was like well screw it I want to see if
I can actually do this and I actually
could and I was very proud of it but the
game just when you're in that flow when
you're doing it the way you do it when
the way they designed it like they
designed an incredible first-person
shooter experience like incredible
incredible first-person shooter
experience I'm just saying if there's
any like post credit stuff they made an
outstanding outstanding first-person
shooter experience like the gameplay as
far as like games go that was stunning
like I didn't think that I would be able
to get to that level where I could play
to that extreme of a style that I I
didn't know that I would be able to do
that and yet I was and I wanted to push
myself to do it farther now my
grievances about the story they still
stand but that doesn't take away from
the fact that this game is fantastic and
in a lot of ways like it's kind of
forgiving like I can forgive this game
for having story shortfalls that I think
could have been better because at the
core this is a game that's trying to
breathe be reminiscent of its 1994 or 93
counterpart the origin of it it's trying
to pay homage to that and build on that
and it's trying to do that by bringing
that story to the forefront and
connecting it they didn't have to do
that they wanted to do that and and I
think it's admirable for them to try to
do that I don't think it was necessary
to do that but I think that it was
all of them to do and they tried to fit
the story and they tried to expand the
story in a big way I think it leaves a
lot more open-ended questions than not
like why did Samuel Hayden know all that
stuff
why is he now just a fixture in the ship
what's the resolution of his story he
didn't get any character development in
this game he's one of the most
interesting characters from the doom
2016 no characterization here just
literally an exposition bot and I think
that's doing a disservice to that
character the doom Slayer himself I made
my point known about what I think about
his character and how its weakened him
as a character overall that being said
these are all just story critiques
doesn't tie into the actual gameplay and
doom eternal I know very much it put a
lot of stress on the story of it and it
actually put the story in front of you
and it made the story part of the game
in almost a in-your-face kind of way but
at the same time at its core it was all
just a mechanism to get you into the
fight and the fight is what matters in
Douma trial because the fight is so
freakin cool period and look at that
look it's all there's no more demon
circles on earth and that's great
let me see in what will hopefully be our
final broadcast to all the people of
Earth to anyone listening the demonic
horde has been defeated the Beast
identified by arc scientists as the icon
of sin was destroyed earlier today
by the Slayer himself and with it the
majority of the demonic force has
dispersed many of the survivors believe
the Slayer to be a god-like figure in
what was a battle between good and evil
of biblical proportions as humanity
struggles to understand what happened to
them and why many look to the Slayer now
for answers but his whereabouts remain
unknown well I mean if you'd look up in
the sky you'd see a weird station up
here but you know don't look too closely
at that it doesn't matter but like I
said it was a plot device like this
story here is a plot device to get you
to the fight and boy howdy they got you
to amazing locations amazing settings
stuff like that the only shortfalls I
would say about the game our blood punch
because I feel like overall it's very
weak the melee being such a weak non
damaging thing and blood punch being and
hard-to-define action in the flow it's
like it doesn't have a lot of emphasis
in its motion you don't know if it hits
all the time you don't really know what
it does cuz you show up close you can't
see it's AoE effect I think it's that's
the only shortfall in the gameplay loop
that I think there is I think it has a
purpose now but it's not an elegant
purpose like everything else has like
the the weapons weapon switching has a
very unique purpose I found myself
gravitating towards many more guns than
I did our doom 2016 that and this one I
was flipping between guns all the time
for different purposes and the only one
I really didn't do very much as a
ballista and that's only because because
I was moving so fast I couldn't risk
being thrown off by this thing blasting
me back I literally was like well I
can't risk that so I won't do it and
that's literally the reason why I didn't
use it is because it did push me back
that looks like the zoom in one didn't
but it regardless it not some
I'm gonna do so gameplay phenomenal I
will also say that the final boss battle
it was okay like it was grand in its
scale and it definitely the second phase
was way better than the first place
because he moved his punches were only
in the zone that he was whereas in the
first phase it was like punches seemed
to come from anywhere and I'm sure there
was a science to it but I couldn't
figure out what the science was second
phase was great I did like the second
phase way better the first phase was a
little frustrating I died quite a few
times he probably didn't see it and I
died quite a few times so with that
being said that is the end of unit
Journal fantastic game well worth the
money by far I can't wait to see what
kind of things they put out to it I do
hope that they take a hard look at the
story because like I know that at the
end of the day it's not too terribly
important and I get that they tried
really hard to write a lot of lore into
it but a lot of lore its convoluted it
doesn't agree with itself all the times
and it's clear some places it's unclear
others and it adds too much complexity
to a story that should be very simple
you know there's there's double cross is
there subterfuge there's heaven and hell
and then there's like when you peel off
the armor of heaven it looks like a
demon underneath that's kind of cool I
would like that just to sit by itself so
people can draw their own conclusions
about it and then with the doom Slayer
like I believe that what I said is what
I stick with I'll leave it at that
however that being said it is their game
and I am NOT a game developer so my
opinion is about worth two shits in a
can so who cares really at the end of
the day because I had fun and that's
what it's all about so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more videos that I've done
I've got so many other things so many
other series if you want to get started
on long let's play of mine that's not
just doom but many other games that I've
played longer series I'm gonna link a
whole bunch down in the description
below check them out there's tons of
stuff that I'm sure you're gonna like
thank you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this and I'm glad you were here
with me hope it didn't make you any of
you nauseous I don't know I was moving
pretty fast there so either way thank
you so much and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
[Music]